[Music]
Kanye West is returning to his old
routine after being hospitalized for
exhaustion the all day rapper stepped
out Friday night to attend a private
opening at the Museum of Contemporary
Art in LA Kanye was all smiles at the
event rocking a baseball cap to cover
his new blonde hair and a shirt that
read don't shun the world and spotted
chatting with artist Michelle Lambie who
put together the rig Owen furniture show
I feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family to really just support each other
no matter what we're going through
though Kim Kardashian has stayed by her
husband's side through the tough weeks
easy flew solo to the art of it and the
reality star has yet to make an official
return to social media meanwhile her
hubby broke his silence on Twitter
earlier this week to explain his
surprise meeting with president-elect
Donald Trump in New York City writing
quote I wanted to meet with Trump today
to discuss multicultural issues
[Music]
you